destiny the taken King Hey Ya Ya me
destiny a man Eric tell you losing his
mind him and Dan mahora could just like
I very excited we got a glimpse of some
of the new sub classes for the three for
the titan warlock and hunter i think i
saw like a glowing acts at one point
there was like an emperor palpatine
esque lightning hands at like did u gggg
and then maybe a bow and arrow uh and or
like it was glowing summon and you know
it's a more hammer 40k nonsense up and
then whether those are sort of in-game
events rate specific stuff or whether
they are actually the subclass uh is i
don't know / first for sure certain
excuse me lesbo there you go oh gotta go
from pray yes yes Tommy hawks buh-bye
the I am dead now I must live again dad
told me how to use it its myspace draws
hammer that's what it is look at this
hammer time it sure looks pretty cool
round is over island in the world of
warcraft i'm not wonderful you melt a
variety that we're seeing a is quite
impressive yeah I someone who's taken a
character up to level 25 and just go
board out to tears with doing the same
crap over and over again I'm kind of
excited to get back into and check it
out it looks like not to let them know
damn oh yeah my dude yet might have put
in a little work
you